we are going to talk a little bit more
about the 2024 Republican primary we
will talk about three potential or
actual candidates a little bit later I
will talk about an actual candidate
Donald Trump we will then also talk
about a potential candidate Ron DeSantis
and first I'm going to tell you about
the newest candidate and I'm talking
about Tim Scott Tim Scott the only black
Republican senator currently in the
Senate from South Carolina has announced
that he is running in the Republican
primary in 2024 the Associated Press
reports Senator Tim Scott makes it
official he's a republican candidate for
president now we're going to talk about
some of the details here but let me
bottom line this for you the 40 000 foot
view on Tim Scott's candidacy is number
one Dead on Arrival number two how on
Earth is the party that most recently
selected as their candidate an old white
guy who regularly stoked fears about
brown and black people how is that very
same electorate going to say hey you
know what
let's elect a black guy instead of trump
when Trump is actually running again you
don't really need to know anything else
about Tim Scott's candidacy other than
that the the same voters aren't going to
go from the white guy stoking fears
about brown and black people to a black
guy they're just not going to do it now
let's go through some of the details
here Associated Press reports Senator
Tim Scott of South Carolina makes it
official he's running Scott the Senate's
only black Republican filed paperwork
declaring his intention to seek the
nomination I love this line
his can't the Associated Press sometimes
they're the the neutrality with which
they report certain things is actually
funny his candidacy will test whether a
more optimistic version of a vision of
America's future can resonate with
Republican voters who have elevated
partisan Brawlers in recent years I can
give you the answer no they are not
going to go with a more optimistic
Vision the deeply religious 57 year old
former insurance broker has made his
grandfather's work in the cotton fields
of the deep south of Bedrock of his
political identity yet he rejects the
notion that racism remains a powerful
force in society he is cast as candidacy
and rise from generational poverty as
the realization of a dream only possible
in America he has ads scheduled to begin
in Iowa and New Hampshire starting uh
this week it's all it's all happening
okay we're really getting into the thick
of the 2024 primary now let me tell you
a couple of different things if we put
aside for a second the undeniable
reality that this campaign is indeed
Dead on Arrival Tim Scott has no chance
he's polling you know one percent two
percent whatever
there is something very dangerous about
Tim Scott Tim Scott openly says openly
says that religion
but not any religion his Christian
religion should guide and direct civil
government in the United States that is
an extraordinarily dangerous Vision now
of course when we look at Trump Trump's
foreign policy ideas are dangerous Trump
being enamored with right-wing dictators
and authoritarians is dangerous Trump's
cluelessness on everything from
International Trade to economics to
social issues it's all very dangerous
but Trump stops short of openly saying
that what was it uh government should
kneel at the altar of religion or I
forget exactly what phrase Tim Scott
used that is also genuinely dangerous in
how Brazen a 180 it is from what the
founders of the United States actually
wanted so is it a good thing that Trump
is crushing Tim Scott and Tim Scott has
no chance well it is what it is I can't
help the fact that Maga still controls
the Republican party we don't want a guy
close to the presidency
who overtly believes that not just any
religion but his religion should control
civil government and that's what Tim
Scott believes now more generally on
politics you know Tim Scott is an
extreme right-winger we shouldn't he's
less cartoonish than Trump in some ways
but we should all understand the degree
to which these are true extremists he
opposes abortion he says crazy things
about the Border he was a no on
conviction for Trump in both impeachment
trials he delivered a completely
outrageous response to Joe Biden's
address to Congress where he said there
simply is no racism here anymore and it
doesn't matter and
according to Real Clear Politics Trump
is polling about 56 percent DeSantis
around 20 as I told you and Tim Scott on
average has two percent Tim Scott is
behind Mike Pence who's not even running
Tim Scott is behind Nikki Haley and
Vivek ramaswamy who are running but also
have no chance Larry Elder and some
polls is doing better than Tim Scott
even though Larry Elder as far as I know
isn't running but who even knows because
no one's paying attention to Larry Elder
so Tim Scott has absolutely no chance
the question then becomes what's the
reason to do this what is he thinking
what does he think he can do does he
literally think he can win over Trump
supporters and convince them to abandon
Trump and vote for Tim Scott no I think
there's no chance in hell of that does
he think that the same party who voted
the guy
into power who encouraged hostility
against black and brown people is now
going to vote for a black guy in the
primary it's very hard to believe Tim
Scott believes that I mean Tim Scott is
a dangerous extremist but he's not quite
literally a stupid guy in the
traditional sense so what is his
motivation
my instinct is that when these guys run
candidacies determined to lose they make
the call that if they can make it onto a
debate stage or two or raise money with
which they can run ads in a bunch of
different states they're raising their
name recognition and maybe securing
their their spot in the Senate I I don't
know I mean it's it's all very confusing
when I see these sorts of candidacies
but Tim Scott running
will not be the Republican nominee
almost laughable to think that he has a
shop and Vivek ramaswamy has no shot
Nikki Haley has no shot it's can
DeSantis do something
to get to 50 percent
and I struggle to think of what that
could be or does Trump just easily
assail to the nomination
one of our sponsors is short form short
form makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and politics to science
and health I was recently checking out
James clear's Atomic habits on short
form of course they have the guide but
they also have highlights they also
include other similar books about habits
and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a
summary of of the book there are new
guides and articles released every week
and short form is giving my audience a
free trial plus 25 off a subscription
which is a fifty dollar value so for the
price of a book per month you get access
to thousands go to shortform.com Pacman
the link is down below